we understand that there is real
pressure on families with mortgages or
businesses with loans as interest rates
go up and that's why we're giving over
three thousand pounds of help to every
family up and down the country on
average this year and last so we're
doing what we can to help people through
a difficult patch but in the end there
is no alternative to Bringing Down
inflation if we want to see consumers
spending if we want to see businesses
investing if we want to see long-term
growth and prosperity and that's why we
will be unstinting in our support for
the bank of England as they go about
their job to bring down inflation